the big game on board one was Hikaru  Nakamura just a half a point behind  magnus carlsen needing to win Nakamura  was unable to press the world number one  and the game ended in a draw I think it  was a very well played game both in  attack and defence none of us could  avoid the repetition without weakening  our positions of it was pretty logical  draw in the other match up world number  to levon aronian hoped to defeat a  lender gata kamsky but in the end he was  under pressure and the game ended in a  draw setting up a big final matchup  between the worlds two best players I  don't want to go home think about  missing my chances be sure to join us  for final-round action of the sink  filled cup live here in st. Louis at  11am central or on st. Louis chess club  com